so before you skip past this part of the
video and go to the 20th best line of
game of thrones let me go over the
criteria for this list at least because
this is a very hard and subjective list
to make and most people in the
discussion post i made asking you guys
what your favorite line is gave a
different answer for me the criteria is
primarily based on the pure quality of
the line of dialogue and that is
generally enhanced by how witty the line
is how well it builds character and lore
how much subtext there is and how good
the literary device is like a metaphor
or a simile lines like i demand a trial
by combat isn't necessarily a great line
but it's completely enhanced by the
moment it is in which to me is one of my
favorite moments in the show but not a
favorite line when compared to this line
money buys a man silence for a time a
bolts in the heart buys it forever it is
basically outclassed because of the rich
use of personification that builds the
morality of littlefinger's character so
hopefully that'll paint a good picture
for the lines that you can expect in
this video
and also i rewatched the first four
seasons and wrote down over 50 lines and
it's been pretty tough narrowing them
down i did get halfway through season 5
but there wasn't any dialogue so far
that could compete with the first four
seasons and i definitely doubt the later
season would be able to compete at all
without further ado here is number 20.
she'll wear this like a badge of honor
[Music]
where is it silence or i'll honor you
again two back-to-back standout lines
coming from the power couple of robert
and cersei my favorite one being
robert's clap back at cersei's clever
little response i love the fact that
george rr martin replaced the word slap
with honor it turns this from a generic
line into an instant classic on top of
there being a layer of irony that
honoring is the exact opposite in this
scenario and then even past that later
we are witnessing this line from the
point of view of one of the most
honorable characters in the show
i don't know how this line managed to be
this great but it just is
i love get the breastplate stretcher but
this one steals my heart because of how
deep it manages to go and how great of a
response it is to cersei this is one of
the first times she gets rolled into
conversation and it makes me so happy
number 19
a good act does not wash out the bad
nor about the good
stannis is essentially a walking machine
of great quotes
they're all pretty good but the reason
why this one exceeds the others is that
this line shows up people are not
two-dimensional and are layered there's
no such thing as just being a hero or a
villain if you do a good deed but do it
in a corrupt way then it's not honorable
however if you make one mistake then it
doesn't mean you are suddenly a terrible
person and every good deed you have done
vanishes
number 18
you are not on trial for being a dwarf
oh
yes i am
i've been on trial for that my entire
life now i'm partially breaking my rules
on this line but it's still a banker of
a line nonetheless i have a lot of other
picks with great literary device usage
but this one is so personal and it
perfectly showcases how much
discrimination tyrion has gone through
his entire life it turns a rigged court
case of tyrion getting beat down into a
triumphant moment of him standing up to
everyone this line just hits with so
much catharsis that it makes you
instantly sympathize and cheer for
tyrion and the line itself isn't bad by
any means considering that you can't be
on trial for who you are as a person
number 17
we mothers
do what we can to keep our sons from the
grave
they do seem to yearn for it
we shower them with good sense
and it slides right off like rain of a
wing
i think that's a great perspective that
shows how much lady elena cares about
her children summed up with these few
lines yearning for the grave perfectly
illustrates how men are so driven to
become a badass knight and aren't aware
that it will most likely mean their
death we even see this in the scene
where renly baratheon dies and loris was
so eager to avenge his death that he
didn't even care for his own and then
the assembly in the third line of good
sense sliding off like a right off a
wing shows how ignorant these types of
characters are even robert baratheon
detailed a lordship character like this
in his talks with sir barristan who
rushed him on a battlefield and died
immediately
this quest for honor and valor is so
meaningless given the overbearing
consequence of death and mothers are the
only ones that can truly see this
because of the fact that it's unlocked
by their love of their sons number 16.
you want to be handed the king you want
to rule this is what ruling is lying on
a bed of weeds ripping them out by the
root one by one before they strangle you
in your sleep that's a damn good
metaphor of what ruling is like in
king's landing
i just love the picture of everyone
trying to backstab you as weeds coming
up and surrounding you
littlefinger varys cersei joffrey all
having their own motives and if you
don't know their motives and keep them
in line then you're done for
ned stark got utterly tangled in those
weeds and he died very quickly but
someone like cersei she keeps those
weeds under control and at times she
completely removes them at the end of
season six
15
never forget what you are
the rest of the world will not
wear it like armor
and it can never be used to hurt you
this is overall great advice for people
held under discrimination while
simultaneously being a great simile
embracing who you are and wearing that
like armor is very uplifting it also
paints tyrion as being a likable
character who sympathizes with people he
doesn't even know despite the starks
technically being enemies to the
lannisters it doesn't stop tyrion from
being a good person i did choose this
initial line as number 15 but even the
line after this is very good
all dwarves are busters in their
father's eyes i would bundle them
together but they are technically
different lines and i personally prefer
the first one all dwarfs are bastards in
their father's eyes is relatively
straightforward in terms of subtext in
comparison to the line i picked
number 14
we could spend all night trading tales
of lost loves
nothing makes the past a sweeter place
to visit than the prospect of imminent
death this is probably one of the most
underrated scenes in the whole show that
a lot of people don't remember because
it's overshadowed by the battle for the
wall but the line itself is such a
wholesome line and it really makes me
want to hug a man targaryen this man
recalling his life and talking about his
past love is pure bliss that needs to
constantly be injected into my ear canal
to make me happier every day
going over all the happy nostalgia of
the past perfectly combats the scary
nature of death and this line expertly
symbolizes that fact and with one of my
favorite characters
number 13. you waste time trying to get
people to love you
you'll end up the most popular dead man
in town personally i really connect with
this line because it's impossible to get
absolutely everyone to like what you
make especially for youtube where there
will be a segment of the audience that
doesn't like what you made there's no
point in arguing in the comments because
as bran said you'll end up the most
popular dead man in town but going back
to the show braun ironically has so many
witty lines for just being a sell sword
and he spews so much wisdom tyrion is
over here molding about people not
liking him while braun is vibing the
whole time
also this line closely resembles what
tyrion's father says and that you
shouldn't concern yourself with the
opinions of the sheep
in doing so it practically compromises
you as a person and you can't live a
fulfilling life in a constant state of
worry all the time tyrion has no chance
in appeasing everyone given his nature
and he just has to accept that
number 12. well my brother has his sword
and i have my mind and the mind needs
books like a sword needs a whetstone
another one of the first classics from
tyrion to me i really can't think of a
simile i like more throughout the whole
show
like generally similes have a powerful
ending to the line when they make their
relation but for this line it feels
consistently great because it shows the
necessity of two different subjects
that being how a mind needs books and a
sword needing a whetstone
it shows the duality of the two most
powerful forces in game of thrones the
ability to outsmart your enemies and to
defeat them with a sword that and it
perfectly sets up tyrion as an
intellectual character by both him
delivering a literary device to
communicate this information and by the
line itself by his mind needing books
number 11
love is the death of beauty that is a
very important metaphor in the show
because of how relevant it is towards
the primary characters each of these
characters have a duty to uphold but if
they're distracted by love then they
can't carry out their duty we look at
daenerys getting distracted by daario
and her having to dump him to save
herself for a proper marriage alliance
tyrion actively ignoring shea so he can
serve the realm and also protect her and
jon's still having to portray egret for
the night's watch
love is the death of duty says such a
massive precedence of realistic and
personal consequences for the main
characters it creates an interesting
dilemma and it leads to a lot of
engaging conflict
also this line is an oxymoron because
love is something that gives people life
and the will to live but in this
scenario it means the death of duty
before moving on nordvpn wanted me to
make sure you guys have one of the best
vpns on the internet and aren't in a
medieval state of no cyber security like
the entire population of westeros their
lives would be so much better if they
had access to some of my favorite
features like secure browsing which
denies any unwanted third parties
accessing your information keeping the
white walker virus out of your domain
with north cyber security which is
included with your subscription that
filters out malicious traffic content on
streaming services isn't region locked
and you can get more content by changing
your location you just straight up get
more free shows and movies that are only
available in certain countries
and even if you are hesitant to give
nordvpn a try they have a 30-day
money-back guarantee
and the reason why i'm so eager to talk
about this sponsorship is that for this
month there's a great cyber month deal
go to nordvpn.com supercuts to get a two
year plan plus one additional month with
a huge discount don't be like an
isolated jon snow upgraded nordvpn today
with my special discount code and become
up-to-date and escape that medieval
nature on the internet of not having a
vpn
number 10. the lion doesn't concern
himself with the opinions of a sheep hey
we're starting out the top 10 strong
with a classic quote from tywin
lannister's first badass scene and this
is such a great scene because it has so
many amazing lines like this the reason
why i picked this one out in particular
is because a this metaphor relates him
back to his house sigil due to the
animal referenced and b it shows the
arrogant nature of being rich because of
that this line also solidifies taiwan as
being a menacing antagonistic force a
man who lacks empathy and who's
extremely wealthy is downright scary and
i also like how tywin sang the song
contrast himself to jaime by the fact
that jaime does care what people think
of him which alludes to how jaime is
much less of an antagonist in comparison
to tywin
that is a man who clearly lacks empathy
while jaime is a man who does not
although at this point in the story it
is buried deep within his character so
even though at first this line doesn't
come across as having a crazy amount of
depth it turns out to have a lot of it
from the hidden subtext
number nine
money buys a man's silence for a time
a bolt in the heart buys it forever i
briefly went over this line in the
introduction of the video but to
reiterate this is a great metaphor that
flawlessly shows how cruel manipulative
littlefinger is that and it also plays
into the political undertones of king's
landing and all the scheming and lack of
trust amongst everyone the fact that a
character like littlefinger delivers a
line like this really shows how evil he
is
personally i think littlefinger is the
scariest and most dangerous person in
the show ramsay and joffrey are both
reckless unlike littlefinger which this
line shows how smart the man really is
and to me that is why i think this line
makes him so terrifying
number eight there is only one god
and his name is death
and there is only one thing we say to
death
not today
although this line relates to death it
is actually a very inspiring quote when
confronted by any form of failure you
need to stand up and try your best and
say that classic line not today i find
myself occasionally thinking about this
line one in those types of scenarios and
the fact that it's not impacting goes to
show how memorable the line is
that and it's also delivered by the fan
favorite serial pharrell and i also feel
like this line brings courage into you
as well as it is motivating overall a
great line to be imprinted onto arya who
essentially lives by this line
throughout her entire journey
number seven
when you play the game of thrones you
win
or you die
there is no middle ground
i feel like a lot of people will put
this in their top three or five but for
me the line is relatively
straightforward and it doesn't have a
lot of subtext or at least in comparison
to the lines ahead of this one besides
that small flaw this line is essentially
the flagship quote of the show and for a
good reason because it really shows how
deadly the game of thrones is
especially since it foreshadows the fate
of ned stark two episodes early
on top of it teasing him getting
betrayed in the same episode and which
cersei tells him that this line not only
sets up the political undertones of the
show superbly but it also features the
sheer stakes that are involved when you
play the game there is technically a
middle ground in the politics for the
throne but cersei exaggerates her point
to ned stark as a form of intimidation
when he was initially trying to
intimidate her earlier in the scene with
the knowledge of her having sex with
jaime and since that is the last line of
the scene it really ends with a bang
number
man dies with six clean sword a rapid
[ __ ] cop
now you probably think i'm crazy for
putting this line so high especially
above the last one but i don't care dude
this is my list and i love the hound
this is obviously my favorite line that
he delivers throughout the show and it's
both so witty and intimidating at the
same time it takes what should otherwise
be a generic threatening line and turns
into a smart and hilarious roast towards
his own men it's just such a clever way
to say that phrase that is essentially
what i think of every time i play call
of duty and my team is [ __ ] the bed
and not getting any kills and i have to
do all the work myself it's so relatable
funny and ferocious
every time i hear it it slams a massive
smile on my face also the hound's
delivery of this line is iconic it
really hypes you up for the first battle
of the show and makes the hound seem
like a complete juggernaut coming out of
the gates
number five influence grows like a weed
i tended mine patiently
until its tendrils reached from the red
keep where i managed to wrap them around
something
very special
similar to maintaining the weeds of
rolling through cersei's line i also
really like the picture the simile
portrays of influence and power being a
network of weeds sprawling around the
kingdom
varys is also one of those characters
who is so mysterious and this line
builds them up as being extremely
powerful despite not looking menacing in
any way
that and it also gives you some
backstory towards varys and how he's
been growing his influence since he was
cut as a young boy along with her
portraying varus to be eviler and isn't
a man turned off by revenge
although he kind of just becomes a
protagonist later on instead of an
unpredictable and dangerous man he was
in the books
number four
any man who must say i am the king is no
true king this is a line that has really
grown on me because of how much subtext
there is behind it it's not overly fancy
in terms of literary devices but i just
love the notion set by tywin lannister
saying this that meaning being that
simply declaring yourself king and being
born into it doesn't make you a worthy
ruler which that essentially foreshadows
the ending of the show
no one chose joffrey and the spoiled
brat is manhandled by tywin lannister
the following line is great by sending
the king to bed but this line has a lot
more meaning on top of it still being
very badass
number three
chaos
isn't a bit
chaos is a ladder i wish i could put
this entire monologue as number three
but chaos is a ladder it's such an
iconic line that shows the pure madness
that is the politics of king's landing
the representation of chaos being a
ladder shows the selfish and
backstabbing nature of the realm so well
in just a few words
which to contrast this to later seasons
it feels jarring when everyone willingly
gives the throne to the starks without
any thought or point of conflict
conflict is the life and blood of what
makes shows so interesting we want to
see everyone backstabbing each other as
littlefinger details and this single
line
this is by far the highest point for
littlefinger's character it remains as
one of the best moments and top three
lines in the show
number two
the day will come
when you think you're safe and happy and
your joy will turn to ashes in your
mouth it's crazy that turian delivers
such a devious and hateful line when he
wasn't in any form of danger since the
scene is sparked by cersei supposedly
finding tyrion's horror
but god damn tyrion you completely
outdid yourself and threatening cersei
here both of these sentences have so
much subtext and background meaning that
it cuts so deeply within their
relationship it's almost as if tyrion
knew joffrey was going to be
assassinated at some point and cersei's
joy would turn to ashes
as for the second line the debt being
paid is all the horrible things cersei
has done to tyrion we don't get a lot of
background stories of when they were
kids so this line accentuates that
amazingly of how much they hate each
other
and then this line comes back in season
4 and essentially evolves given the
recent events
number one
power resides where men believe it
resides
it's a trick
a shadow on the wall
and
a very small man can cast a very large
shadow wow a double whammy metaphor and
essentially the thesis as to what game
of thrones is and how people hold power
people choose who they follow and they
empower them with their support even
though this line is number one i
struggled for a second putting it here
because of how much david and dan reused
it in season eight men decide where
powell resides how are his eyes where
men believe shut your mouth god that
actually tilts me instead of coming up
with their own great writing they
continue to recycle george rr martin's
dialogue from the earlier seasons
but taking that out of the equation the
line itself builds varus as a character
by showing him caring for the realm and
him thinking that's where power resides
it has a lot of depth and it uses
literary devices expertly
and a very small man can cast a very
large shadow line really empowers turin
and makes him seem unstoppable in the
earlier seasons
this was him and varys prime and this
single line in moment is what i loved so
much about game of thrones utter
perfection
so yeah those are my top 20 lines of
game of thrones obviously this is my
personal opinion and i doubt anyone
would make a similar list from the sheer
amount of magnificent dialogue in the
show to choose from if this video does
well though i think it would be fun to
do a top three lines from each season so
there's more variety
because for this video all these lines
are from the first four seasons and that
wasn't because i was lazy it's because i
genuinely couldn't find a line of
dialogue i liked more than what was in
the first four seasons on top of having
50 of them but regardless though i hope
you enjoyed the ranking and thank you to
nordvpn for sponsoring this video
you